قال قائد مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه
للحشد لمواجهه القاده العسكريين الروس
بعدما تهم وزير الدفاع الروسي باعطاء امر
لقصف قواته في احد معسكراتها باوكرانيا
ونشر بريغوجي ما قال انها صور للقصف مشيرا
الى انه اسفر عن مقتل عددا ضخم من قوات
فاغنر وتوعد قائد فاجنر بالرد مشيرا الى
ان ما يقوم به ليس انقلابا عسكريا وانما
مسيره لتحقيق العداله على حد وصفه بريجوجن
قال ايضا ان مبررات القاده العسكريين
للحرب على اوكرانيا بنيت على اكاذيب وذلك
في اول تشكيك من نوعه في قرار الحرب في
المقابل نفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قصف
قوات فاغنر ووصفت الادعاء بالاستفزاز
الاعلامي بينما قال الكرملين ان بوتين
مطلع على تطورات المتعلقه ويتم اتخاذه
جميع
عندما كنا نقتل في باخم الدفاع عن شرف
روسيا وجيشها خدعنا وحاولوا حرماننا من
امكانيه الدفاع عن منازلنا كنا مستعدين
للتسويه مع وزاره الدفاع وتسليم السلاح
وبحث مساله كيفيه مواصله الدفاع عن وطننا
الا ان هؤلاء الاوغاد لم يهداوا ووجهوا
ضربه على معسكراتنا الميدانيه قتل عدد
كبير من مقاتلين ورفاقنا سنتخذ قرار الرد
على هذا الفعل والخطوه الاتيه هي لنا
واضاف بريجوجل ان ما يحدث في البلاد فوضى
ودعى الجيش والبلاد باسرها لمسائله
المعنيين ووضع حد للفوضى حسب تعبيره
عددنا 25 الفا لماذا في بلادنا هذه
التعديات 25 الف احتياطي تكتيكي اما
الاحتياط الاستراتيجي فيضم الجيش بكامله
والبلد كلها كل من يرغب في الانضمام
فلينضم لابد من وضع حد لهذه الفوضى